[Music]
foreign
[Music]
nelson mandela
letters from prison
hope is a powerful weapon
a letter to his wife winnie april 2
1969
dear winnie
every day i remember that hope is a
powerful weapon
even when all else is lost
you and i however have gained much over
the years and are making advances in
important respects
nothing will harm you my darling
you are in my thoughts every moment of
my life
i think about you when i close my eyes
at night and i will be heartbroken until
the morning you are by my side when i
awaken
but until that day comes please send
more my patriot supply
i love the cheesy macaroni as well as
their scrumptious oatmeal
however the pudding is transcendental
one tastes
and it makes me feel as if i'm no longer
a prisoner in this world
it provides a fantastical
taste of escape that an incarcerated man
like myself so desperately needs
in fact
it turns out i like my patriot supply
even more than you
a future man told me that we get
divorced in 1996
but that pudding will always be by my
side
yours for now
nelly
p.s
please do not tell anyone about how i
like to put tires around people's necks
and light them on fire
send pudding
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's june which marks louder with
crowder's seventh annual cultural
appropriation month where we take you
across the globe learning about and
appreciating all the diverse cultures
this planet has to offer
because to appropriate
is to appreciate
this week we transport you to a very
special portion of a majestic continent
the land of lions giraffes and apartheid
the birthplace of such wonderful whites
as elon musk and charlize theron
south africa
[Laughter]
i'm very happy to uh own twitter
that's because it was look i know we're
just kind of scraping the bottom of the
barrel with this one we're looking at
south africa but you can see
my spacex spacex there we go don't
really see it do i need to the moon i
need to get off she won't be there yeah
yeah look at that yeah it's not shibuya
that's a different way
we don't exactly have jim henson on the
payroll here uh really glad to be with
you
so we're going to get to let me just set
this up we're going to get to joe biden
on jimmy kimmel last night i know
everyone's talking about it
unfortunately i haven't really seen very
adequate fact checking the most
difficult part of today's show
is 20 something minutes is about what
the segment was
every phrase was a lie
everything i'm wondering every single
phrase every single phrase is a lie
how do you
how where do you start this show would
be i mean the show would be three hours
today if we were to just go through it
so i just picked the most egregious lies
uh the ones that are numbers
well i use less executive orders and
donald trump i'm sitting like he does
know that we have those numbers correct
like he doesn't know that i am one click
or one thumb press away
from fact checking that lie
snopes nothing
yeah his audience won't look at it
though snopes no
do we no politifact you're no kojak when
it comes to this right no columbo all
right thanks for your detective work so
i wish we didn't have to do this it's
cultural appropriation month i'd like to
have a little more but oh my god no one
wants to do it no we'll do it don't
mistrust your institutions so uh as we
do that today of course we are live on
rumble monday through thursday uh you
can always watch us monday through
thursday at 10 a.m eastern uh and of
course we have a full hour on mug club
it's chat thursday
and today is of course cultural
appropriation month so um you can send
your costumes in uh oh we're using the
hashtag lwc south africa that seems
complicated
uh
south africa i just think it should be
hashtag cultural appropriation month use
either one of those and we do have the
promo code right now for the next 24
hours 20
off uh for mug club an annual
subscription and use the word culture
use the word culture and again we're
demonetized on youtube uh we pretty much
just stay in business because of viewers
like you and i don't mean that in the
sense that pbs says it and they're
funded by the federal government which
technically is viewers like you it's
just your tax dollars against your will
it's by force right
we're supported by viewers like you not
through force
so uh what do you think let me ask you a
question today before i bring everyone
in what do you think was the most
egregious life from joe biden
on uh jimmy kimmel
i i i don't know where to start but all
of it let's introduce uh our lovely
people here today of course uh the
atomic
not exactly
yours is clearly the most identifiable
gerald a it's very clear that you're
charlie's theron it is yeah mine i was a
little like this is just a guy in a tux
we know who you are it is and i have to
say uh all of you guys out there who are
getting top surgery i think the novelty
kind of wears off in a few minutes and
you're like just they're in the
yeah show those guns bro you know yeah
you look jacked look at that they're not
they're not really there anymore no they
are farmers
oh i do have the pharmacy why do you
have a farmer's tan i don't think you've
seen the sunlight in half a decade i
believe it's permanent at this point
by the way it just came out born with a
white trash yeah i tanned like how can
we make him look like a trailer park kid
i don't know right there his 23andme
reached trailer park
no so i i want to make sure all of our
contests like commit okay yeah look at
me right now do you send i want to be
like this commit if you don't send in
good costumes we're not going to do
cultural appropriation month anymore
this is seven years seven years and
we're running out of countries we are
running out of countries but i do have
to say i'm glad we chose this one
because you sir are my favorite
african-american yep i am just such a
huge fan you know it's funny that you
say that and i don't want this to be
like an ass shining contest like jimmy
kimmel and joe biden you charlize are
absolutely my favorite african-american
except in monster that was gross
that's fair you don't need to subject
yourself for that you're hot just own it
and be hot yeah that's true can we pull
up a side by side of who wore it best me
or charlie sarah yeah let's do that for
a much later on later on yeah
twitter spoiler alert
not this guy come on
i can't believe he suspected himself he
thought it was him
and then of course okinawan is working
over there uh taking your chats he's a
tank tank he's the uh blade runner who
killed his girlfriend
and uh oh what do we have uh casey uh
who i i'm afraid to ask i'm trevor noah
good morning steven oh jeez he does a
good give me some trouble oh well today
we're not going to talk about joe rogan
saying the n word over and over again no
no we're going to talk about our my
homeland south africa yes thank you and
by that you mean that you're absolutely
going to talk about joe rogan is the end
you have to expose him he's absolutely a
terrible terrible man of course
[Laughter]
safari tool man and then uh you know him
you love him he's always back uh you
know when dave has to be on the road
it's his birthday happy birthday dave
quarter mandela quarter black how are
you sir
thank you
thank you i only served a quarter i was
offended whenever i found out that dave
might played mandela so i i called you
there was no chance that he was going to
say no way we said we need to we need a
ringer
and by the way it's nerd erotic is your
podcast where can people find it the
channel is nerd erotic okay and uh the
show is friday night tights on fridays
oh okay so but we just had alex jones on
last week really yeah it was really good
did you have him in studio you just did
by skype zoom no it was zoom okay in his
studio but it was a lot of fun yeah so
yeah but now you know what my job is
like corral that guy yeah right you're
like all right come on we gotta start i
love them no look look i i know i'm
starting wait is this live you're like
we've already been live oh okay all
right i should have drinking that he
brought out like a jersey
from like red dawn and he brought out
his shot
youtube button it was awesome and he was
about he licked a hallucinogenic toad
that was before the show that's
definitely not a gay frog here's my
fluoride carbon do you mind if i promote
oil of oregano you're like just do
whatever just do it you do you alex he
jumps into the live reads just like ben
shapiro does you don't even see it you
don't even know it's coming
all right so actually since it's
cultural appropriation month because to
appropriate is to appreciate it's time
for some facts that you may not know
about south africa
oh that's common oh i'm using comma too
when we get our equipment from south
africa yes
just our team members so
to learn about south africa again
because you should always learn about
other nations i don't know if you know
this it's not all about you america it
actually is so south africa has uh the
fourth highest uh hiv aids rate in the
world really yep receipts any receipts
for that mm-hmm wow south africa is
actually the largest producer in the
world of platinum yeah and uh yep yep
nelson mandela once said education is
the most powerful weapon which you can
use to change the world now where all
the stupid white [ __ ] at
wow yeah that's yeah yeah it's not as
thank you that's been around for a while
it's not as ubiquitous people don't know
about it
the first heart transplant in the world
took place actually in south africa in
1967. that's great 18 days later the
patient died of double pneumonia well
but not of heart no exactly that's a
different thing yeah it's a different
thing so once unrelated yep extra nine
days it's like you know you get a
vaccine and you start
uh neil blumkamp
told the hollywood reporter that filming
district nine was quote the most
difficult thing for me to experience
since washing apartheid end so that's
pretty yeah that's that's a difficult
thing that's been south africa facts
i'm glad that you guys learned something
no i know it's south africa
i mean i'm going to invent things and go
to mars we'll talk about more on my club
even when i travel to ireland then when
i
you guys have it so so good here in the
united states you don't realize how much
more convenient your life is i'm not
saying ireland is a third world country
at all it's clearly not but even then
just restaurants are not open nearly as
often the idea you know here you go to
quick ship you can get whatever you want
you have fast internet you have any kind
of cell phone service plan you want
everywhere else in the world when people
talk about south africa what do you
think it's just johannesburg i'm like
okay but have you have you actually
looked at how people live there it's
still yeah it's not even close listen
you have enough safety security and
prosperity to complain about your
pronouns yes that's it yeah it's pretty
safe we live in a safe if you don't have
a war against anyone else you war
against yourself
you do and your body apparently by
adding things to it and cutting things
you're a wiener which by the way i
really appreciate that you committed to
that but uh you don't get that bad top
and bottom so let me move on to this
this is something before we move on to
jimmy kimmel and in biden i didn't want
to spend some time on that today because
oh my gosh so dishonest
i don't even know how much he knows that
it's dishonest but before that
another stupid person uh yesterday joy
behar and here's the thing i don't use
the term stupid lightly no this is wow i
don't think i don't think that nancy
pelosi is stupid
i don't think yes i don't think whitmer
is stupid i don't think kamala harris is
stupid i don't think that biden back in
the day was that stupid joy behar is so
mind-numbingly dumb she is sitting at
that table and she's not even having the
same conversation as anyone else around
her yeah she just she's like that old
lady who just starts naming things that
are in her line of vision like
jail cell you're like yes that's what it
is yeah
picture like that's a grocery store okay
you can say words
so jay joy behar uh had this to say
on a panel of black women
most ar15 owners are former military
thirty five people
so that's all i'm saying okay
here's the thing once black people get
guns in this country the gun laws will
change trust me
[Laughter]
the lady looked at her like
like what
wait hold
[Laughter]
oh my goodness wow now i believe the
implication there
what are you trying to say joy she's
trying to say that if black people had
guns white people would be afraid of
them and so they would try and remove
firearms from them i guess yeah sure
where where's the joy you ignorant [ __ ]
yeah
she's past that point no it's just the
insult at the end right yeah uh i think
she's trying to say that white people
are racist and that if black people
here's the problem with it
a huge portion of black people already
have guns according to 2017 pew study
this was 32 of black households on a gun
that's a third
of black households for comparison it's
a little it was a little less than half
for white households right about 49
so more white people a third versus
slightly less than half you're like okay
in other words it's not like we're
trying to keep slaves on the plantation
and by the way
black gun ownership has gone up
dramatically because of people like you
joy behar right in the wake of yet floyd
taylor you had all these riots two
billion dollars in damages we had a um
professor uh professor officer dorne's
wife on the show who was slaughtered by
someone one of those neighborhoods
trying to help his own community a black
police officer so so black gun ownership
went up by 58 yeah now i had an asian do
this math who works here because uh i
didn't want to get this wrong so if you
were to estimate we don't have these
numbers now there isn't the data the few
research was 2017 then you look at this
article from the hill all references
available at lot of credit.com that
would put black household gun ownership
at around 50.5 percent
so more than white people in 2017 yeah
more as a percentage that's great by the
way does she think there are laws that
prevent black
you can't peop in here jamal no right
not for you there's some black guy's
going in to buy himself a walther and
someone's just like rejected get that
[ __ ] out of here
like it's a 1950s diner yeah
peter you come on over here tom you know
listen if black people could go and buy
guns and they didn't have fire hoses and
german shepherds everyone we could all
eat pie
joy
you're the racist yeah joy you're the
racist hey to be clear i've advocated
this uh i want as many law-abiding
black gun owners in the country as
possible yes please absolutely more of
them taking applications now be
fantastic it's so funny to me too when
they talk about the gun control issue
and they say you know we need a screen
to make sure the right kinds of people
are getting these permits okay i get it
but it's not perfect but if you look at
the concealed carry permit statistics
they commit less crimes than off-duty
police officers yeah
this is the most law-abiding demographic
that you can find is concealed carry
permit holders in this country yeah and
that's why i want more of them that's
why i want more people not only only for
owning firearms but carrying them and
joy behar can't even comprehend that she
was probably talking to a lady a black
lady who owns a gun
well she was just reciting statistics
about
military and a lot of the military are
black it's like does she not realize
that she's talking about black people
right then it's
because like what you just said she's
not even having the same conversation
she's like drifting in and out of like
listening and she's like yeah but black
people don't have guns yeah well the
other lady had just made a really good
point she's like people with ar-15s are
not crazy people you guys are demonizing
them and joy bae here's like but if
black people had guns you know it's like
the only thing
she said something smart that she
couldn't agree with but she couldn't
dispute with facts and so she's like
what black people had guns we'd change
the laws
okay well look hey how about this i will
go on the record and this might be on
i'm not afraid to take the risks do it
uh i want as many law-abiding black gun
owners as possible and i want fewer gun
laws
shocking what and you were people i'm
willing to take the risk that i get that
i get shot by a black guy with a gun
yeah i'm willing to take the risk i know
joy behar i know that you live in fear
of that because you know black but i'm
okay with it with her private security
yes for private security some of whom i
guarantee you are black and the building
security do you think she went into the
green room and one of her black security
guards were like hey you know that
[ __ ] you said about
that
hey there's a guy here to kill you but i
don't have a gun you know that's oops
you know that was really messed up right
like you dumb as hell
[Laughter]
have you i mean you have seen me every
day you have seen my ass with a gun
every day
you even said show me your gun
nothing but a gun and a smile and i
found a sexual harassment suit and now
you don't know that black people have
guns stupid crazy [ __ ]
come on joy yeah their last show we were
mission we had security guards who were
black guys i see black guys with guns
all the time i don't understand why this
scary enjoyed behar nobody's afraid of
that
i mean if you're in an opposing gang
well in chicago listen enjoys community
they don't allow black people to have
guns and so she's just speaking from her
small community of reference they don't
allow anyone knowing guns in new york
that's true she thinks it's because
she's italian
you know listen yeah you know why it's
because i'm it's because i'm uh because
i'm a guinea that's not why no it's
actually by the way it's because you
didn't pass the background check joy no
one time in college all right
so let's get to uh former vice president
joe biden on on jimmy kimmel for for
record you watched the full clip yeah i
did yeah and quarter black guy did you
watch the full hell no
23 minutes of my life i was hoping you
would just show it to me okay he's the
best bird stephanie yeah
jimmy kimmel yeah that sounds like he's
celebrating the halo series on paramount
i can't get enough of it i don't even
want to talk about that let's just move
on this is very nerdy i don't know what
you're talking about we'll go back next
thing i'm gonna start referencing
basketball
no i won't come on look whose name is on
the ledger don't get me lost in tall
grass here
halo that's no i actually did play halo
on xbox my last generation of video
gaming was the last game i played all
the way through was fable on xbox i love
fable yeah it was fun it's dude it's so
deep remember people complained about it
deep bro they were like it was not
open-ended enough i might just stop i
remember just everyone takes pointless
it's a good time you're saying music
like if it's pointless you just run
around and do nothing speaking of
pointless that's a segway thank you also
the guy well you know i'm going to ruin
this right talking about how the guy who
invented the segway died by driving his
segway off a cliff still the funniest
story in there he just segued right off
the cliff yeah in south africa right
look at that little known fact oh that's
true really yeah a lot of cliffs in
south africa and we brought it back of
course not so speaking of uh pointless
and uh plummeting to your death that's
how i felt i wanted a tomato
former vice president joe biden
i think this was him but i don't know if
it was him or it was just some you know
bent back paper clips and masking tape
uh kind of holding him up but uh he
appeared on jimmy kimmel so let's set it
up and then get to the the worst the
worst lies but there are so many
wonderful to have you here goodbye
maybe you want me to just stay on fox
all the time
you know they're very concerned that i
might not ask you serious questions so i
don't know i really ask serious
questions about hunters
i don't want to upset them at all do you
mind if i ask you some serious questions
because this is um unfortunately i never
mind having a conversation with someone
really smart well uh guillermo maybe you
need to take over
okay before i get into anything else i
know you'll say this is ad hominem like
i said 20 minutes every sentence almost
every sentence was a lie that's not
hyperbole
joe biden
just though he moves like someone who
knows that if he just touches something
incorrectly everything's going to break
he's very calculated
if i put my elbow here am i going to
crack my humerus oh
i'm in pain oh let me put my foot
everything hurts everything about that
remember when they made a big deal about
donald trump drinking a glass of water
yeah oh god that was like a week-long
straight of just look how he holds it
right he's like shaking a little bit oh
my god he's like on a staircase he's
gonna die right which by the way i have
to use two hands if i'm drinking
something after the gym yeah so it
wasn't a consider but the point is joe
biden lives his life
like a terpid sloth
that's too much stability
uh hold on i gotta put one foot in front
of the uh
he plans on five breaks a week my point
is this is a man who is very clearly old
this is a man who this is a comedy show
if they wanted to actually do their job
there would be at least some jokes about
the fact that he's a demented old circus
monkey but instead they're acting like
he's this wonderful president and it's
fawning praise this is the disconnect
between the media elite the
entertainment media industrial complex
and you even the people who voted for
joe biden for former vice president joe
biden are not watching this saying that
uh all right that man is uh that man is
a pillar oh
fantastic that is strength a pillar of
robust youth hercules over there look at
him all right so let's get to a few fact
checks here uh
he of course was discussing gun control
like joy racist behar and he decided to
make his case uh directly to americans
on jimmy kimmel because of course
overwhelmingly americans reject the
actual policies when they know what they
are so here he is here's what has to
happen
all of you folks and i hope her and i'm
not being facetious when i say this
hopefully republicans here as well
you've got to make sure that this
becomes a voting issue
it's got to be one of those issues where
you decide code will your position on
the issue senator or candidate for house
or senate
on what we're going to do on us with
assault weapons and how have maybe it'll
have 300 rounds in a magazine
i mean
what you say
people in the house and congress can
take responsibility for it but it is our
fault because we need to
stop this
we need to do it
okay and this is of course it's all
painted right with the tint of
we're the only ones who care yeah we
need to stop it the way we stop it is
with guns again we were removed we had
our shows removed you can watch all the
banned episodes you have a promo code
right now culture 20 off on mug club
there's the band archive because we said
there was going to be a mental health
crisis yeah that if you were going to
see an increase in suicides which we
were seeing dramatically that typically
there's a trend line that's relatively
consistent with homicides and violent
crime due to mental instability we were
talking about this in relation to the
coveted lockdowns boom removed and now
they say we need to stop this so now
they want to remove your second
amendment rights by the way they're
surrounded by security in that studio i
know that's not lost on you but why why
let's let's before we get to some of the
fact checks think about this for a
second why would joe biden want to
make this a single issue voting election
uh on guns
and that's make no mistake they want you
to focus on guns and abortion
and they want there to be riots and
marches over guns and abortion well call
it a hunch
but there's some recent polling coming
out this is may 27th uh this is from
harvard harvard kept harris poll 55
percent of respondents strongly or
somewhat disapprove of biden 63 say the
country is on the wrong track 62
disapprove of the handling of inflation
56 disapprove of crime handling
immigration they disapprove of the
economy let's compare this to trump at
the same point 63 percent of voters had
a favorable view of the economy
and that's typically the most important
voting issue his overall approval rating
former vice president joe biden 39
remember 39.7 remember when they used to
say that donald trump was the most
unpopular president ever and that's also
why you know fair and square which we'll
get to in a second lost that election
most safe sir secure election in history
fortified
of course you can't go watch on mug club
episodes that were banned from youtube
not on that topic don't do it spoiler
alert i don't think it was the safest
secure election in history just so you
know that's just my opinion i'm not
allowed to substantiate it
because that would be misinformation
against the rules so 39.7 biden against
the least president at least popular
president history donald trump at the
same point during his presence he was
42.7 ah
so that's higher yes but yeah i don't
know numbers three points right i'm
doing the math correctly here and so
what they have to do is look it's pretty
and i understand there's more to the
economy than just joe biden with gas
prices i understand that it's not just
joe biden i understand also the federal
okay i get that it's not just a straight
a to b line however there is a direct
contrast that you see
and we have a contrast that's more i
would say more stark than ever
throughout our lifetime because think
about it when we grew up okay clinton
and george w bush not that big of a
difference honestly if you go let's go
ronald reagan you know george bush
senior clinton george w bush
okay not a huge contrast right they all
were relatively big government somewhat
cons bill clinton was a moderate
democrat george w bush was a moderate
centrist right
contrast that you would have had would
have been jimmy carter to ronald reagan
that was a contrast yeah that's what
turned that generation to conservatives
forever we in our generation have a
pretty stark contrast eight years of
barack obama and former vice president
joe biden then three years of president
donald trump i don't count the last year
because of the covet sham that the
democrats perpetrated and then you have
another you will have another four years
of former vice president joe biden so
you've got eight three and another four
and at a certain point it's so easy a
child can do it they go wait a second
gas prices go up okay economy not doing
as well all right we all know what we
were living under president donald trump
mean tweet but everything was better and
now we're back to the same old crap yeah
well i i don't even like the way that he
started out the segment he's like you're
talking about these 300 round magazines
i'm like you're using an example that
doesn't exist in these crime statistics
at all like at all
show me the last crime that somebody
committed with a 300 round magazine like
that was not i don't know that i've ever
seen a 300 round magazine i think so
i've seen drum magazines at uh like
maybe a hundred yeah and even then it's
more of a novelty like no one would rely
on that for defense you're thinking he
knows anything about guns that's a fair
paul nobody that's he's saying this he's
turning to the american people and he is
the former vice president of the united
states of america trying to make an
argument about a very serious problem
that we're all dealing with and he says
something that is so completely untrue
that video games don't even have it
right
and then he says we have to get rid of
these kinds of things and it's like well
that's not the problem no joe you know
why he does that you know what he has to
obfuscate it so here's the reason they
want to make it about abortion and gun
control not about the economy not about
energy policy not about foreign policy
not about what affects your life right
they want to make it about abortion and
gun control
and this is why they're not outraged at
the leak that took place with the
supreme court they're not nearly as
outraged about the attempted murder of
uh justice kavanaugh um as they are
about you owning a firearm is they need
to take those issues because they feel
that they can obfuscate them more oh
pro-choice when you look at americans
most americans define themselves as
largely pro-choice when you get into the
statistics regarding where there should
be limitations on abortions
the vast majority of americans would
agree far more with many of the
republican bills that have taken place
at a state level same thing with
firearms if you poll americans they say
well yeah a majority of americans
support sensible gun control policy then
when you look at the individual policies
and you actually explain them to
americans the vast majority of them are
against it and the reason he has to say
300 remember he used to say you don't
need 40 rounds that's what he said just
fire a shotgun into the air which is a
which is a crime yeah by the way you're
now endangerment it's former vice
president elmer fudd i don't know what
he's thinking
but he said fire the shotgun because
batman's going 50 rounds but here's the
thing now at this point in history
americans this for the same reason that
we just gave you that stat earlier all
references available a lot of credit.com
more black gun owners than ever
americans now go i have 50 rounds my
city's on f sounds about yes that sounds
about right 25 rounds because in
california it's banned at eight i'm
sorry i banned it 10 in california and
you have to have a bullet button
maggie mcconaughey was talking about
three shells from migratory birds
american
values he has to say 300. he has to say
300 because saying what's realistic you
know an ar-15 you're typically looking
at around 40 round magazines
um with handguns on average you're
looking between 12 and 15 a concealed
carry handgun might be 10. no one thinks
that's unreasonable people go 300 that
sounds a little bit weird yeah if if
you're talking about mass shootings
taking place on the back of a wagon with
a gatling gun yeah exactly most people
are like can i get a link to that 300
that's kind of nice on yeah for prime
delivery or how do i get it i get that
next day yeah
300 rounds all right stupid so that's
why your times out here yeah yeah
exactly yeah
it's arnold schwarzenegger fella he had
it yeah
[Laughter]
so when he was talking about gun control
measures um
kimmel actually had a question
it was interesting because here's the
thing you think this isn't a softball
question unfortunately there was zero
follow-up i thought maybe kimmel's
asking this because he actually you know
has the answer and instead it was hey
here's a layup it's like t-ball it's
like t-ball for lies former vice
president joe biden here is former vice
president joe biden just flat out very
easily
provably lying about executive orders
can't you issue an executive order trump
passed those out like halloween
candidates yes sir
isn't that something that could happen
well i i have issued executive orders
within the power of the presidency to be
able to deal with
these everything having to do with guns
gun ownership whether or not you have to
have a waiting all the things are within
my power but what i don't want to do and
i'm not being facetious i don't want to
emulate keep saying that because abuse
of the constitution and the
constitutional authority
and
and so
and i mean that's the story because i
often get asked look the republicans
don't play it square why do you play oh
please yes well guess what if we do the
same thing they do our democracy will
literally be in jeopardy zip it okay two
things before i get to the fact that
that's absolutely untrue well you know
let me just let me just hit you with
this first hundred days biden issued
more executive orders than than trump
than obama then clinton and bush okay he
averaged 67 executive orders per year
compared that donald trump 55 executors
per year and donald trump a huge portion
of his executive orders were really just
undoing obama's executive orders which
by the way were unprecedented so just to
be clear that's a straight out lie but
two other things you ever had a mechanic
or you ever known somebody who always
tells you like look i'm not gonna lie to
you or they say to tell you the truth
yep that's a red flag when you're at the
third to tell you the truth you're going
what were you telling me before
yeah
look i'm not being facetious here that
implies that you were being facetious
earlier and then this is and donald
trump did this too but he was more
clever about it
uh because he would have alibis but
[Music]
joe biden goes and everyone always asks
me why do you play so why do you play
square when republicans don't he's like
the steven seagal of former vice
presidents that's why steven says other
people
they uh they tell me you're amazing
i had the dalai lama say
you are
buddha incarnate like it wasn't me who
said that that was the dalai lama sounds
like you joe yeah it sounds like you mr
seagal well the worst part of that at
the very end was when he said this
threatens our democracy we our democracy
could crumble and i'm like this is the
point where in this video like i
actually had to pause like for a minute
on the video and i'm like
he believes this not only does he
believe it the audience believes it
because they clap jimmy kimmel believes
it because he reiterates it either right
then or at some point later in the show
about democracy karma like
do you understand what you're saying
you're the very people that are a threat
to the democracy that we have because
you're saying government needs to
control more and more and more people's
lives republicans just want freedom for
you that's it uh hey
we're not a democracy well we're true i
understand that but we're a
constitutional republic but you're right
but i understand but the point remains
he's full of it and he doesn't
understand it's like typically the
people
people who want to allow citizens to
keep firearms keep in mind here this is
very important i think a lot of people
miss this it's not about the hypocrisy
of course all these people have armed
guards i get it right yeah and they
don't but it's the issue at hand the
underlying issue here is they're not
saying that they shouldn't have the
right
to protection and firearms they're
saying you and if you look throughout
history that is the bit as a matter of
fact it's always
sort of the foundational red flag of
what could become a trinical government
if it's not tyrannical today it
absolutely will be if you allow them to
remove your firearms this is something
that it's also the first generation
that's ever demanded less rights look
people talk about a compromise on gun
control
compromise means what there's a give and
take
i want you to you know what comment
below this is a genuine question
outside of abortion and drugs
where are the democrats and of course
that's just a lie but where are they
ever offering to give you more freedom
look at the gun control policies where's
the where's the give it's just a take
it's a magazine it's limiting firearms
it's limiting your ability to finish up
what's the give
what's the give hey how about this how
about if there's a give like oh and by
the way you know what if you do pass all
of these back i'm not saying that i
would approve of these policies but if
they said if you do pass all these
background checks and these stricter
measures we'll remove that's uh the
class three stamp that you need to get
for example uh a suppressor silencer you
can buy that just like any other firearm
because you've very clearly gone through
it and that's ridiculous let's get rid
of some red tape it's only a take
there's never a give it's only a take
and democrats on every single issue joe
biden we're going to lose our democracy
you're the guy who wants to take take
what take the choice of what you can
drive yeah if not make it so so
expensive that you can't drive it so
unaffordable and so expensive as far as
fuel that you can hey take what you can
eat we need to cut back on meat if not
make it so expensive through policies
that you're not able to eat meat you
should be eating crickets take
take how much money you have in your
pocket
take which school you can attend not to
mention firearms there's no give
so when people say both sides man look i
get it republicans are pansies and i
have a problem with a lot of their
spinelessness that being said the
democratic platform
saying we're going to lose our democracy
how are democracies usually lost
assuming that he doesn't understand this
is a representative republic i get it
how are democracies usually lost
they're lost by people in power
accruing power by removing freedoms from
the citizens and that is every single
policy that has been proposed outside of
abortions taxpayer funded and uh you
know free crystal meth in the state of
uh of oregon well give them a single gun
law that they want right now and when
the next mass shooting happens because
it will because you didn't solve the
problem we gave you practical solutions
about arming people in gun-free zones to
make sure that people couldn't just walk
in and shoot willy-nilly go ahead make
all those gun laws when it happens again
we need to take a little bit more
because we didn't take enough and that
would happen we didn't do it we need to
take a little bit more because it didn't
happen we didn't take enough from you
how many times you have to say for this
that's it how many times you have to say
well look at chicago
california look at all these
new york all these people the criminals
still have guns look at 94 people mass
shootings it's not going to change
anything that's not what needs to change
is people's moral compasses like the
matthew mcconaughey speech it was really
great
until the second half when he started
going into red flag laws and all these
things the first part was great we need
to return to our family values our
american values those are the things
that we need to go back to because if
without those you have
deranged people that will cause harm
that was called pandering well yeah of
course right
but yeah no but you're right without
those without morals
deranged people will cause harm
regardless i'm not saying like no laws
for anything but
to just create arbitrary laws like
everyone that he listed were completely
arbitrary yeah changing the age what is
that gonna do they're gonna okay oh i'm
a crazy person so i'm gonna change the
next three years yep that's not gonna
change anything hey how about giving
values all right how about 21 to vote
you know what how about just id to vote
21 to buy a firearm
make it one age for everything or
just
no you know what no no option b make it
one age for everything no you can be
enlisted if you can be enlisted you
should be able to buy a beer if you can
it's just one of those things you have
16 with driving and learners and then
you have 18 you can be enlisted and you
can be traditional and then you have 21
when you can drink and now they want to
be oh you can only own you get but only
we're talking about uh ar-15s and not uh
well handguns are already 21 so maybe
some right look make it one h one h to
vote are you saying that 21 is a new 18
fine there needs to be a give and a take
it's only take it's only take it's only
take until you get so far along down the
trail
where you say hold on a second wait i'm
a parent and i'm not allowed to stop my
child from being on puberty blockers
less child protective services come in
and take them away which by the way has
happened
very small amounts so you don't care now
until it affects you that's a lot of
people
i'm not being facetious
that means you are all right so here he
goes and he says uh uh
well this is one where he kind of makes
a joke but uh he's not joking i
understand that argument but also it's
like you're playing monopoly with
somebody who you know won't pass go and
won't follow any of the rules and how do
you ever make any progress if they're
not
following the rules
uh you know there's that little box
directly to jail
can you imagine i get that it's a joke
can you imagine if donald trump joked
about just jailing dissidents wow which
by the way is what you've done with the
january 6 a lot of the them sorry you
call them insurrectionists uh maybe
you'll be able to find two among them
maybe trespassers
right vandals yeah you want you want
that's what they are the people who were
there protesting peacefully and there
are those people they're political
prisoners oh you got to put him in jail
and this is also what's interesting
is uh
he plays so square that's right he plays
so square and talks about putting
political opponents in jail that youtube
has to ban any videos that question his
square play of the election it's so
clearly square that twitter facebook and
youtube have to remove any content that
questions the safety and security of an
election to ensure that you uh tell him
consistently as one does that joe biden
is right he plays it so that's what they
tell me tell me i play so square
polygon four sides equal thanks that's
just weird but i love how kimmel says
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
well you're not done no not a trap is
white was that a comma trapezoid is a
diagonal
it's concave convex there's a
you're talking about right angles same
length
vector points
that's my favorite math
it's in the square root
because
it's like that um sesame street song
it's hip hip to be a square by the way i
really like those muppets that say yes
all the time that's fantastic
no campbell says they don't play by the
rules what he was talking about before
that was not letting barack obama put
another supreme court justice on at the
end of his term and also saying for them
to get anything passed right now they
have to go by the what what what senate
rules that say yeah that you have to
have a 60 vote otherwise they can
filibuster that's the only they're
playing by the rules that are on the
books right now exactly what the hell
are you talking about do they not like
the filibuster now they don't like it or
they do like it it's confusing it's a
fair question goes back and forth joe
biden has come out and said that the
filibuster should not ever be touched
right that's a fair question i just
think i think you and joe but the reason
you're not understanding you're so far
apart you're more oblong
ah
is it like wobbly
i don't know circle like shaped like a
rhombus yes
yes
yeah that's uh that's it
by the way my wrong boys popping on this
one popping a rumble popping out of this
yeah
[Laughter]
it really is that hey you know what i
think is playing you know what i think
is sort of playing against the rules
just yeah well they're talking about uh
yeah president barack obama and they're
talking about you know trying to appoint
supreme court justice um
completely and knowingly falsely
accusing
a supreme court justice at that point
nominee of gang rape
i don't know i think that is if you look
through the rule book it's not like air
bud like there's nothing in here that
says a golden retriever can't accuse a
supreme court justice of gang rape but
actually there is there is yes yes
it's called defamation slander so i
think that's again you know for me i
don't know i think that's against and
then also accusing the other one gorsuch
of being a neo-nazi being a fascist in
college hey you know what i think is
against the rules a [ __ ] witch hunt
which by your own admission about donald
trump with peeing prostitutes in russia
i think that's against the rules i think
straight up lying
or saying things like 300 round
magazines which by the way i don't think
appears anywhere in the legislation
that's proposed and by the way
by saying i don't think means i know
it's not in there i think that's against
the rules
call me old-fashioned and by the way
here's what uh jimmy kimmel thinks of
you
the american citizen this all makes
perfect sense
and the fact that this makes sense is
why it doesn't make sense and why it
seems so crazy and that we have so many
problems and that's so brilliant maybe
it's just that americans aren't as
knowledgeable as they should be or maybe
there's a uh a death star pumping false
information into our box right or yeah
or maybe
or maybe it's always been this way
oh the irony ship it's not stopping
it's rolling right through he's on abc
yeah by the way partners with disney
and you're bitching about fox news yeah
abc nbc cbs cnn msnbc cnbc
fox news
this is going to be them the other ones
thinks fox news is the death star yeah
it thinks fox news maybe americans need
to educate themselves hey uh
tell me what a semi-automatic
yes tell me what a semi-automatic weapon
is three hundred brown magazines
yeah do me a favor tell me what a fully
semi-automatic weapon is yeah define it
and i do think that americans need to
educate themselves i do i don't disagree
with that but i don't think you're dumb
just because you're a gun owner that's
the issue there is they want to
pigeonhole you and remove your rights
jimmy kimmel is the worst he well his
last sentence there was dumb he
basically said i don't know if it's been
this way all the time or maybe people
are just uneducated or maybe there's he
just basically was like i have no clue
what's going on what do you think yeah
save
somebody give him a prep document okay
please get a prompter over there that
has a few points on it so it doesn't
sound like the [ __ ] he is how bad it is
because this is all prep right like this
that's not a natural conversation that
you just had they practiced it it's a
script that's how late night shows are
made they had to put down swords and in
that they couldn't plan
like with no facts or anything they just
put down
shock absorbers and uh joe biden still
cracked his
play that forearms play that last clip
again of jimmy kimmel and i think it is
uh clip i yep this all makes perfect
sense
and the fact that this makes sense is
why it doesn't make sense and why it
seems so crazy and that we have talked
about passages at times and that maybe
it's just that americans aren't as
knowledgeable as they should be or maybe
there's a uh a death star pumping false
information into our box right or yeah
or maybe
or maybe it's always been this way can i
just look
think about this for a second okay
you've got jimmy kimmel by the way hats
off to that crowd animator with the
applause sign i know that guy is
probably in a coma yeah think about this
you've got jimmy kimmel
okay
and this could have been any of the late
night shows yeah this could have been
jimmy kimmel this could have been
colbert could have been jimmy fallon
take your pick any of the netflix i
don't even know what the other shows are
right now
that are out there seems like there's a
new one every single week and then it
fails so you've got abc you've got nbc
you've got cbs you've got most of cable
abc is disney nbc is universal uh cbs is
viacom i believe
cnn is turner so you've got jimmy kimmel
sitting there
on by the way with his own salary is
more than our entire
probably two-year operational budget
yeah his own individual salary probably
his executive producer's salary his
showrunner's salary so you have him
sitting there on one of the most
powerful networks in this country one of
the original three
with
the sitting former vice president of the
united states
and you have facebook
and twitter
and youtube which is alphabet you know
controlling 90 plus percent of
information out there who have openly
said that they lean left and they have
openly decided to work with the white
house they even say they lean left but
they said they're working with the white
house to fact check information so they
have right there you have an
encapsulation and this was uploaded to
youtube that's where we pulled it
you've got jimmy kimmel abc
all of the networks right all of the
media all of the entertainment industry
the white house
sitting right there president former
vice president and then president harris
and then you have it being pumped out
and favored all of you probably know
that this is showed up as suggested or
it's very easily searchable it makes it
to the top of trends on all the major
and that's still not enough they want to
take away fox news they've got to get
rid of episodes of this show do you see
where the fight is think about that how
do you think
democracy crumbles
you've basically got people more
powerful when you combine them then the
old romans if if you go back to rome and
you go to the day and the republic they
had the senate and the if if they all
got together senate emperor instead of
ides of march they all just met up and
we're like let's just all do the exact
same thing and take everything from the
plebes they're like yeah good still
that's what's happening right there
entertainment industry all of hollywood
all of media the white house and all of
big tech
and they have to create a villain they
think fox news is the death star
this show is the death star because they
can't compete so they've got to remove
it hey you know what maybe that
coincides with why it's so important to
take away your guns
they've tried to take away your access
to information
they've gotten pretty far with that
that's why i also recommend you go watch
on rumble support us promo code culture
get 20 off on mug club don't if you
don't want to it's what keeps the doors
open
we do have a target on our back
had a lot of legal issues to deal with
this week dealing with youtube
and it's still not enough
when is it enough
the only thing left is you the citizen
that's all that's left
stolen couldn't oh i want control i want
control of the the media okay you got it
i want media to be larger more powerful
okay you got it
want to count the votes okay you got it
i want to be able to project my message
everywhere across the country okay you
got it
and i want other people to not be able
to question me okay you got it fact
check removed what more is there
i get it seizing people who argue
seizing the means of
production and distribution as far as
socialist economically but i'm talking
about culturally and your acts your
rights what more is there for them to
take
oh democracy might crumble if we don't
uh remove everything else
and by the way that's also why
this is going to be hard to lift
oh we do have a few sponsors here and
they have the balls to uh support us uh
well it's patriot supply hatred supply
yeah well this is one of those things
remember when i told you guys i said you
don't need to have you don't need to
believe that there's going to be some is
it what is it not emt what's the term
the electronic emp yeah emp emt is the
people who clean up you know the blood
dmt is where you get yeah loopy gmt's
where you look at you see the aliens bro
you don't need that to happen to just be
prepared for an emergency do you hey did
you guys wish that you maybe had some
spare toilet paper do you maybe wish
that you stocked up on gas i went
through the baby formula shortages baby
so i think also it's very clear what
used to be considered a prepper or crazy
uh now people say oh yeah it's probably
a good idea to not rely on uh you know
my government to be honest for my food
and for my autonomy so uh we do actually
have right now there's a promo code
three months of food per person if you
go to prep with crowder.com you'll save
150 on a three-month food supply so
that's prep with crowder.com three month
food supply they've got everything in
there i have a couple of these at home
some water a way to heat it up i lived
through the ice storm in montreal where
we didn't have power for days and days
and there was no way to get food so yeah
it's not like it was foreign to me to
prepare when you live in an ice cold
climate you all have that yeah by the
way if you're worried about rankings
these guys have forty eight thousand
four and five star rankings right i
wasn't worried but then customers no
customers say they're good yep they are
they're oatmeal and they're good it is
very good i was very irresponsible
nelson mandela loves the pudding i love
the pudding i came home after a couple
of beers and i was like well i don't
have anything i got some oatmeal on it
is that why you need more that's why i
need the machine
i'm not going to pay quaker
i have quaker dollars
quaker
big quaker
big oatmeal
yeah that's what by the way you need to
talk about fiat currency what's going to
be the new standard uh reserve currency
and saying it's not the united states i
i'm quite convinced it'll be kohl's cash
grain because white i didn't control
everything
i've been saving up on that calls cash
yeah that calls cash is that a thing
where they mark something up by 500 to
mark it down by fifty percent yeah
you're getting a z you think i don't
know this but i know it's fifty percent
off you're like yeah but it was it was
nine hundred dollars for a pan yeah you
buy the dip you showed me the cost
by the dip diamond hand all right
oh that's right look i got this we did
get the blood yeah yeah
blood diamond hands
here's the funny thing too people think
because i'm a conservative that i'm like
i'm a big consumer you know this i don't
buy anything i actually have very little
use for money it's pretty much
everything i earn is for my children
future generations i i don't get the
diamond the jewelry thing i mean i know
what that man it's like
and it's not just because oh third i
understand the whole concept of blood
diamonds i just think it's really stupid
yeah the idea that we pay so much for a
ring and that people get convinced here
well it should be x amount of your
salary it's like a shiny rock look at it
yeah
and then you're like well i have a shiny
rock like that's the that's the fake
shiny rock don't love your life yeah but
this one is 10 000
but i can't tell that it's the fake
shiny rock shouldn't that be enough yeah
but hold on but if you come here and i
get this thing hold on a second i'm
going to tell you how what a worthless
piece of [ __ ] fiance you are give me two
minutes does anybody he doesn't love you
it's a fake industry it's a couple
industries it's probably crazy
and by the way
women watching i want to hear your
opinion on that comment below because i
know yeah you'll likely in theory agree
and then you want one anyway
yeah yeah
come on that's always what happens you
can't say no to a diamond i don't want a
big wedding oh great wait till we see
the bill 800 people yeah
it's just the actual people in the
diamond mines oh this wedding's the
worst i remember digging up that diamond
reception catering by boston market
would be much they thought i stole it i
took my fingers
all right
yes my thumbs got blood all over my hand
now right now okay let's get to the
kavanaugh thing by the way uh because
this is important so you know uh uh
supreme court justice brett kavanaugh um
falsely accused of gang rape that's
important by the way yeah falsely
publicly falsely no completely false
verifiably false anyone who thinks
there's any validity to what christine
blasey for it has been proven false yep
just so you know don't that's one of
those things where you don't need to i
know we all all the references at
loudlycross.com okay provide them to for
every single show if someone you're
talking with in your life says what
about brett kavanaugh and before they
can finish the word
rape just re just slap them and tell
them none of that [ __ ]
and moving indelible in the hippo campus
something yeah i'm a doctor i mean i
made it up okay uh no i understand i
appreciate you understand a lot uh what
was the address
well well that was not well you're not a
doctor
okay i don't know i understand i
understand a long time ago can you tell
me like the rough neighborhood you're a
prague
how about the house are you a sexist oh
i think he's a sexist about anybody that
you told that will now say that you're
telling the truth
well there's becky
oh my god i'm going to have to prescribe
myself i don't have her number anymore
though so
some xanax we should totally put you in
front of congress we'll do this tomorrow
yeah can't wait
pottery barn here i come
my doctor it's like diamond let me get a
big diamond but oh my god i don't have
any popsicle sticks just put in the
mouth and this day's the worst you
shouldn't be a doctor of anything hard
you shouldn't you should be in a
straitjacket all right
so uh kavanaugh by the way still not
encouraging the kind of violent attacks
against christine blasey ford that
they've encouraged against sitting
supreme court justice uh brett kavanaugh
so it was wednesday yesterday uh that
was june 8th for people who are
listening on audio just because
sometimes we'll listen to this later on
so 26 year old the guy was uh is it
nicholas rosk
rosk roski roski rosk
i want to make sure this is something
i've only read because i try and avoid
watching other people's commentary
this person was arrested attempted
murder supreme court justice brett
kavanaugh in case you don't already know
this i'll just give you a quick recap uh
and uh this is also um is this is this
the is this the statement from the uh
the white house right here this this is
the criminal complaint criminal
complaint against that's the criminal
complaint yeah white yes that's a way to
wipe okay just for people watching i
have a small monitor so sometimes i
can't see what's up there when it's
locked it's not the size of the monitor
that matters the point is he didn't use
[Laughter]
why because you caught him doing it
[Music]
you know
i don't know we could uh fudge it yeah
so yesterday
just just so everybody understands
yesterday they're like let's just be
clear he wasn't arrested at judge
cavanaugh's house they were trying to
like downplay this and they were getting
a little bit but this specific point he
got out of a cab in front of kavanaugh's
house saw two u.s marshals and decided
to walk down the street at one something
in the morning yeah the only reason that
he didn't go to the front door and break
in was there were two u.s marshals in
the driveway oh dang i didn't know they
worked this late no they caught him way
on the other side he wasn't even close
to in harm i'm kind of surprised why
didn't the marshals just kick the [ __ ]
out of him right there like didn't
didn't you suspect it when he walked out
saw you and started whistling hi-ho and
running away
are you looking the other way i was just
looking for a house for sale in this
neighborhood you know we're gonna beat
the [ __ ] out of you right sir yeah judge
kavanaugh's house ah that's not where
i'm what this is
kavanaugh
wow
ah u.s marshals love the movie you guys
have drivers just like that yes that's
right there is justice kavanaugh's house
the one you said you wanted to shoot
shut up oh no
he's drunk
he's giving him tips
it's just the air fresheners have gone
to his head and they don't work the last
time i use uber what did you bathe in a
vat of gin this morning so
here's what the democrats had to say yes
on this situation someone trying to
assassinate a sitting supreme court
justice
uh from thewhitehouse.gov the president
condemns the actions of this individual
in the strongest terms and is grateful
to law enforcement for quickly taking
them into custody any violent threats
threats of violence oh what any violent
threats threats of violence this is joe
biden speaking this is as redundant as
you can possibly imagine any violence
threats or threats that's a violence
i forgot about that i read it early this
morning i was like what an idiot or
attempts to violently threat yes
look we're not going to take any violent
threats
well and also
we're not going to take any threats of
violence
and even if there's violence when you're
saying something that's threatening it
every guess that's going to be a hard
pass
and then also
we don't want you know if you're if
you're violent if you're saying you're
going to do something violent and that's
a threat too
huh
weird get over here let me lick you
well give me give me 12 minutes i got to
put my forearm
it's not going to look itself
base
three points of contact i need an epson
shot
so let's compare that right now where
threats of violence violence threats we
condemn this right that's what they
strongest possible strongest possible
terms which by the way is a way of not
actually issuing the strongest possible
terms what are those
as strong as possible can you say those
instead of saying the strongest possible
we would but we already said the
strongest it's less strong by the way
than donald trump condemned the
neo-nazis at charlottesville who should
be
who should be
totally condemned okay i'm not talking
about them who should be totally some of
you if you're if you're new to the show
you may not know that because they
showed him saying
very fine people on both sides he said
who should be condemned totally
condemned totally is different than uh
strongest possible terms are we good
we're good we're good fine okay and then
outside of it we're not good they still
cut it out just saying if we're playing
by their own game so let's contrast this
strongest possible terms umbrella term
which means nothing with the biden white
house former vice president's white
house on the january 6th violence
let me be very clear
the scenes of chaos of the capital
do not reflect a true america
do not represent who we are
what we're seeing
are a small number of extremists
dedicated to lawlessness
this is not dissent
it's disorder
it's chaos
it borders on sedition wrong
and it must end
now
were there also threats of violence
he's like hold on i forgot we're
violating the strongest possible terms
yeah and the strongest possibility i'm
just saying just compare you know how he
felt about trespassers now here's the
thing i don't want to play the game that
liberals do and say that we have a lot
of conservatives right now saying the
left they were encouraging acts of
violence now there has been that yes
kamala harris with the riots
uh maxine waters there have been actual
calls to violence just to be clear
there weren't direct calls to violence
against justice brett kavanaugh however
if we're playing by the standard that
the left applies to everyone who is not
them
let's look at chuck schumer who by the
way i don't know if you know this chuck
schumer
did his he he lives not in your head he
lives at the gates of hell ah perch to
top cheap housing he's adjacent to very
cheap he's hell adjacent yeah
keeps him warm so here he is telling the
supreme court
what the democrats have in mind for them
they're standing republican legislatures
are waging a war on women
all women
and they're taking away fundamental
rights i want to tell you gorsuch i want
to tell you kavanaugh you have released
the whirlwind and you will pay the price
smirky face afterwards by the way not on
and this is the problem with you know
going back to what kimmel said about how
americans are maybe they're ignorant now
here's the problem that you see from the
left they're misinforming you
the implication there is that you vote
for supreme court justices you don't
you don't and that's for a reason
you know schoolhouse rocked that [ __ ]
you might learn a little bit three
branches of government so he's saying
you will pay the look at what they're
trying to do you will pay the price well
hold on a second hold on a second these
people have already been appointed so
him saying that you will pay the price
you can look at a lot of the rhetoric
and you can see the consequences with
someone attempting to murder justice
kavanaugh
no accountability i'm not seeing jimmy
kimmel asked about that that happened to
the day jimmy kimmel did the interview
with joe biden just to be clear
yeah should have come up should have
come up maybe if it was on his heart in
the strongest possible terms hard
questions yeah
it's hard to touch my heart here because
there's there's so many i know there's
the boobs which by the way afterwards
don't take that off right after the show
you and i are going to no we're not
take it oh no close the blinds in my
office
so let's compare what they said about
uh
the justices
the consequences
versus what they claim was a call to
violence from donald trump for january
6th keep in mind that was a big reason
for impeachment but i said something's
wrong here something's really wrong
can't have happened and we fight
we fight like hell and if you don't
fight like hell you're not gonna have a
country anymore
our exciting adventures and boldest
endeavors
have not yet begun
my fellow americans for our movement for
our children
and for our beloved country and i say
this
despite all that's happened the best is
yet to come
so that and pull up pull the clip also
as well where he was in that same speech
saying peacefully basically he went out
of his way
voices voices make your voices heard but
that's the worst part yeah
that's the clip that they played
saying uh this was a threat of violence
he was calling people to violence by the
way you should fight like hell life is a
fight resign yourself to the fact that
your life
your it will always be a fight
you don't have a choice this is
something this is a problem you know you
have this i i say this uh
respectfully but we've talked about
white middle-class women who vote
overwhelmingly democrat
and i can't tell you how many it's super
it's alarming the increase in female
viewership that we've seen how many
people send me messages particularly
even after the baby formula shortage
saying i just didn't pay attention
because i didn't want i didn't want to
talk politics with my friends because i
didn't want it to get ugly that's
because women
temperamentally are often better than us
because you want to be agreeable
unfortunately guess what you don't have
a choice you don't have a choice to
avoid the fight so if you're going to
fight fight like hell guess what you're
already in it you're already in it you
can't what you're gonna what are we
supposed to do roll up and die yeah
you're gonna turn it up and die
no and and here's a really quick
comparison too i found this lori
lightfoot tweeted this out and i think
we've got an overlay for it here um said
to my friends in the lgbt plus community
supreme court is coming for us next the
moment this moment has to be a call to
arms that's a very dire statement that
was one month ago that she made that
statement and it's like there's like oh
this doesn't this doesn't exist like
they're not saying go out and physically
do this listen if you feel like the
election has literally been stolen from
you
what should you do
that's that's a question that we all
have to ask ourselves i'm not saying
what they did on january 6 was correct
i'm just saying you can understand why
they would be mad about that and by the
way that's why they say you're not
allowed to feel as though it isn't the
most free and secure election of all
time otherwise we'll remove you right
because you know what happens that's
what actually leads
to more violence to civil war yeah when
you say you're not allowed to feel that
and people say i kind of do though i
need to talk about about all these
feelings
you're not allowed to feel that way
you're not allowed to think that but i
kind of do think it you don't want any
part of this dewey i think i kind of
want it
that's what's happening yeah exactly
well and then and then in in this
specific example here
they're literally saying
in black lives matter protests and
rallies with the george floyd verdict
with all of the other things that we
have seen the trials to get out in the
streets to go and do things we saw it
every single night and they didn't
condemn it right they didn't come out
they encourage strongest possible terms
you guys have to go home and stop with
the foolishness of burning down your
cities and now they're doing the same
thing and setting us up for another
summer of rage and going but the
kavanaugh thing doesn't matter it
doesn't matter that they went to a
judge's house to try and kill him
because he has an opinion that states
ought to make their own let me just use
it let me let me distill this to
something very very specific remember
how they said and by they i mean the
media and the democratic party but i
repeat myself remember how they said
they came in
with with noose with a noose and gallows
to hang mike pence can you know research
team get that to me within one minute
let's bring that up the picture
of the noose
you wouldn't be able to hang a border
collie it was it was obviously meant
symbolically they were they tried to
convince you that they were going in
there to hang my
vice president mike pence yeah okay
by the way if you just go to the [ __ ]
march and you see all these violent
images look i understand i'm not
necessarily a fan of them on either side
i think it was really stupid to have
that yeah there i think you were given
the media ammo that you didn't need to
give them just like i think it's stupid
to wear vagina hat but that's me mr old
fashioned the point is they said look
they were going there to hang mike pence
oh the [ __ ] this guy showed up at
justice kavanaugh's house
with a gun and a stated motive to murder
him
there you go
you actually think there's structural
integrity to that no that's like a four
foot nine person that can barely fit in
how much whatever you have i'm like i
got this five foot piece is that enough
okay i'm so against this idea i don't
like hanging people we should tar and
feather them yes ah yes see you know
that's more humiliation yes and it lasts
longer
with the you know flaming team it's just
it's not too far it's so stupid but
that's what i would do
i would do that for everybody tonight
they're gonna have the the hearings
right this is gonna be political theater
we will cover this next week we're gonna
distill it down for you and give you the
highlights for it but this was great
fertile ground for us to get banned
covering it live because i don't know if
we could have we were going to cover it
live tonight saying true things things
that you can go out and research yeah
comment below maybe i don't know maybe
i'll do it myself with a
webcam don't do that because no one else
wanted you're just going to be pissed
but did you see the entire the entire
media yeah all the networks have shifted
their coverage so they can cover the
january 6th yes
and then they said fox news couldn't be
bothered to have this on their air yes
because it is absolutely moronic it's a
political theater stupid you want to
talk about something fine let's talk
about the person that shot ashley
babbitt let's talk about people that
have been denied their rights because
they've been charged with sedition for
trespassing and held in
jail
and yet paul pelosi gets out after a dui
catch and release charges in san
francisco no problem people that commit
crimes aren't deported from this country
even though they're here illegally right
that this sounds fair right
i bet yeah think about it for a second
someone's sitting there going wait a
second uh am i uh you're arresting me
because i was on the
capitol lawn with a sign yeah oh well
you know i used to live in san francisco
and i took a [ __ ] on somebody's doorstep
and stuck a heroin needle in a fake
mustache in a girl's restroom and uh
nothing happened so i am surprised that
this is going to be my permanent record
it is i just don't understand the rules
anymore well and people are going and
this is one of the most frustrating
things because you lose the ability to
fight legally for yourself because what
they're being told right now
is yeah well no
i'm saying legally fighting in a court
of law
with
lawyer terms words with words you can't
go and defend yourself because if you go
look i didn't do anything they're like
look you're facing 25 years in prison do
you think the courts right now are going
to side with you do you think the united
states government which is what is
arrayed against you in the court of law
do you think they're going to let you in
any way shape or form get past this you
have to take a plea you have to take a
prison sentence so that they can get a
win otherwise they lose and it's a huge
black eye to them because this is what
they've been pushing that's the case
that's where people normal people not
criminals not radicals find themselves
right now yeah they have no way out yeah
yep they're saying goodbye to their
families for years for trespassing yeah
that's unbelievable it is absolutely
there was a an open letter written from
someone uh actually who was charged and
it was absolutely heartbreaking was
talking about life has completely
changed doesn't mean that you doesn't
mean that two things can't be true
you're pissed off at the people who
barged into the house you know and and
smeared their nuts on nancy pelosi's
desk and you're like well that guy's
yeah i agree that's a little bit too
much and also understand that people
shouldn't be brought up on
charges and sentences worse than
murderers yeah for trespass yeah
this is the problem and then and then
people like jimmy kimmel have the gall
to say maybe we need to remove anyone
who isn't telling people this about
january because it seems that there's a
problem maybe we need to remove any uh
source that doesn't say that uh people
are running around with 300 round
magazines maybe because that's a problem
maybe that's their solution is what do
you think is going to happen they have
reached so far i mean think about this
for a second going back to the kavanaugh
issue we have the clip of uh i believe
former vice president joe biden
alluding to revolution now this we're
always careful we have to walk on
eggshells that's why we have this on
rumble and we have it on rum we have it
on mug club as well
but they're talking about revolution the
sitting vice president we're concerned
about using that word saying look if you
push people too far you might actually
get to a point where people feel like
they have to revolt i'm saying that
that's the cycle historically whereas
you have the sitting former vice
president alluding to revolution
simply if states are allowed to
place restrictions on abortions
it's clear that if in fact the decision
comes down the way it does and these
states impose the limitations they're
talking about it's going to cause a
mini-revolution they're going to vote a
lot of these folks out of office
right
right
because arresting people and giving them
longer sentences than murderers for
walking across some grass yeah and
locking them up and keeping them away
from their family and banning people and
voices and opinions and doctors yeah
from all social platforms that's that's
you know that's less of a reason for
revolution than uh placing restrictions
on abortions let's say in the state of
texas uh
after three months
that requires a call to arms which by
the way someone took you up on it lori
lightfoot
someone took you up on it
if anyone should be charged
yeah you know what i'm i'll get more
trouble if i say anyone should be
charged it's that crazy bug-eyed [ __ ]
and guess what
more people will be offended than i said
that rather than her calling people to
arms with a guy doing it
beetlejuice beetlejuice beetlejuice
don't say that
you
don't say that three times damn because
then he'll show up no she'll show up oh
we don't want her she doesn't even show
up anymore she's her assistant worst
the so pretty bad too yeah it's like is
it a prerequisite for you all to have
crazy eyes what how do you have an
office full of people working in this
office i can't help it we're doing our
best
[Laughter]
basically
if you put her and aoc together you
could see 360 degrees around ah
feel like a dragonfly put them back to
back like tango and cash
[Laughter]
vision is off the chain back to back so
uh before we go we have cultural
appropriation months we're going to be
taking your costumes and your chat here
on mug club today sorry today's show has
gone a little long because of the lies
jimmy kimmel break it down mcconaughey
you weren't here yesterday there quarter
black garrett uh the tone deaf call for
american value man traditional yeah back
to it red flag laws by the way uh this
is actually uh has brought us to uh this
week's
matthew mcconaughey his anti-gun films
has rebooted anti-gun films this week
seven plus one
[Music]
you'll forgot to find in the chamber
and by the way this is matthew
mcconaughey who's chosen to do this
because a lot of his films showcase
firearms right yeah and so he's decided
that he's done a lot of he's done some
damage he recognizes it he's owning it
and he's uh rebooting some of his old
films
to uh you know reflect his current value
okay yeah on on firearms so these are
the top seven plus one
matthew mcconaughey it's a little bit of
a stretch matthew mcconaughey
rebooted anti-gun films
quarter black give us number seven
number seven how to lose your rights in
10 days whoa
that's not so bad i think you need the
gunshot a little louder there right if i
heard that it just came it was a silence
suppressed seven plus one anti-gun
matthew mcconaughey films give us number
six gerald uh failure to trigger lock
yep he has a problem with that you
should have responsible gun owners got a
trigger lock bro number five the not so
free state of jones ah
no they use guns in that one right seven
plus one re-branded anti-gun
yeah i almost said matthew broderick oh
wow matthew mcconaughey films uh number
four dallas buyback club
that works
i like that one
seven plus one number three matthew
mcconaughey anti-gun films uh we are
martial law well that just seems almost
like he's tipping his hand yeah just a
little bit mm-hmm oh it's sad i really
liked this uh this other one i like the
original and i don't i don't really like
the rebranded one so much it doesn't
seem like there's as much of a of a
feel-good ending so yeah quarter black
give us the number two
time to be killed a time to be killed
yeah that's yeah yeah
yeah that doesn't seem when you can't
defend yourself i see i get it i don't
know how they're gonna write that script
yeah
it's difficult and the uh number one of
matthew mcconaughey's rebranded anti-gun
uh films tazed and abused yeah that's
what's gonna happen if you uh of course
if you give up here what happens yeah
don't tase me bro falls on deaf ears and
the plus one uh is tragic mike this has
been this week seven plus one
[Music]
we can cover it later or we can we can
do it behind the paywall if you want we
can do it for mug club or next week yeah
i don't know what do you think yeah
let's keep moving in let's let's i know
all right we've gone kind of long here
okay we've gotten kind of long all right
so look we're gonna take chats uh uh
here and we're gonna take your best
costumes the costume contest for
cultural appropriation month this
continues it's every thursday it's the
last day of the week uh throughout the
month of june and uh boy we've been
doing this a long time where i don't
know how much longer we can go so uh
leave a like if you can share that helps
because sharing is caring comment below
uh
you go and hit those i'll hit the like
button
rumble
mug club promo code beautiful culture 20
off nerdist is his show not the nurse
[ __ ]
i told you before the show i was like i
i in my head i just i'm telling myself
don't say nervous don't stay nervous
don't think it's
a nerd erotic that's like every teenager
when it's a woman you're like don't look
at her
don't do it don't do it
i'm sorry i can't help myself
again
how dare you i have
they're right there
i feel so violated your boobs are huge
what is the name of the show what yeah
did you have a sounder for that give it
give it nerd
on fridays with the friday night titans
products get a lot of people together
the promises last week nerd you're
supposed to be intelligent make some
create some more original names youtube
piss off
[Music]
you